what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today i am going
to be talking about five things that
i've learned from watching manosphere
content for months um anyone that's been
following my channel knows that i have
been reacting to the manosphere for
about maybe four-ish to six-ish months
um before i start don't forget to
subscribe to the channel and bring that
notification bell that way you're going
to be notified of my daily videos
for anyone that doesn't know um
manosphere
i should look up the actual definition
but the manosphere is basically like
men's dating advice and men's
self-improvement advice and it also
includes something that's called the red
pill and
i've never seen the matrix so i hope i
get the analogy right but basically the
red pill is
um
when you take a pill and like the way
that you view the world changes um so
you see like all the bad parts of
society and like the bad side of women
um
yeah
so that's the red pill
um let me look up the definition of
manosphere the manosphere is a
collection of websites blogs and online
forum promoting masculinity strong
opposition to feminism and misogyny okay
the manosphere
are movements within the mammosphere
includes men's rights movement in cells
men going their own way pick up artisan
fathers rights groups um so i would
probably describe it a little bit
differently
um i don't think it's like super
misogynistic or like anti-woman or
anything i really think it's just like
pro-man um
and like
helping guys like become a better
version of themselves for girls that's
like how i would describe it um i do
think that sometimes like men get a
little too caught up in it and caught up
in all the problems that there are in
dating because there's obviously a lot
um
but like that that's how i would
describe it okay
so um i'm basically gonna tell you as a
female like what i've learned from
watching men for like
months just talk about their problems
because when you start to watch
manosphere content you really understand
like men in a different way than you did
before um
i don't think society really talks a lot
about men's problems and so i think like
in the mainstream media there's just a
lot of stuff you don't really think
about
so the first being
men are very tired of being used for
their money
um
so i've seen this theme like in the
manosphere where
the reason guys get super caught up in
the manosphere and start watching men's
dating content is because
they've spent like hundreds of thousands
of dollars on a girl they've
given these girls all this time all this
attention
and
they end up like getting nothing out of
it
and
so i used to if you look at one of my
old videos like we talked about like a
guy paying on the first date
and i always said like i would never go
on a first date with a guy if he
didn't pay
and the reason are on a second date with
a guy if he didn't pay on the first one
and my thought process was
okay if like
a super attractive female came in um and
he had a first date with her he'd
probably pay
or like a model came in and
so like my thought process was he's
probably not that interested if he
doesn't want to pay on a first date
um after watching the manuscript content
for months um what i came to realize is
a lot of guys are sick of being used by
women so women will go on dates with
guys for food um they will
literally just go on dates with guys
with no intention of ever talking to
them again they just wanted a free meal
for the night and guys are really sick
of it so a lot of times
guys will
literally like
not do that because they're just really
sick of being used
um that's why personally like i'm okay
with in the beginning stages not
spending a lot of money on the first
couple of dates because
like if we don't know each other
like what's the point like me and my
boyfriend like
it took a while before we ever went on
like a nice a super nice date until we
like knew each other better
okay um second thing i've learned
men are afraid of marriage but not for
the reasons that women think so women
think that men are afraid of commitment
and in my opinion i don't think men have
changed in the past hundred years
so you know a hundred years ago men were
getting married all the time so i don't
think it's the long-term commitment that
men are afraid of from what i've seen
they're more afraid of the court system
so
if you get married and it doesn't work
out
like women
can and will take
all of your money um there are cases
where men's have to men have to pay
hundreds of thousands of dollars spend
their life savings even if they don't
have a kid with the girl um i forgot
what it's called but it's like
when you spend paint like when you have
to send someone payments just for like
being married to you um so from what
i've seen like men are more afraid of
that
than the long-term commitment because if
you ask most men
most men want to be married at some
point it's the court system that i
really
think
makes men a little bit more hesitant
about getting married okay the third
thing that i have learned from watching
manosphere content is that
women today are less marriageable than
ever before for a guy to find a girl
that is agreeable that is pretty
that is in shape low body count from
what i've seen in the manosphere it's a
lot harder than women think um so
honestly like
i think girls have more leverage today
that are in that category than ever
before because
girls are so rare that are in that
category
um however on the flip side
men that are in like the top five to ten
percent
have more options than ever before
because so many more girls are willing
to have sex with them like immediately
right away
um so that's probably the third thing
that i've learned is that like finding a
quality girl
is harder for men than ever before um
one because men have to deal with all
these games like
they won't even know if a girl is
actually interested in them or just
using them for their money clout like
whatever it is okay fourth thing i've
learned from the man of sphere
and i'm not going to talk about if this
is true or not true um this is just how
a lot of guys see it women are always
willing to leave you for a better option
um that's the way a lot of guys think so
it's really important to some guys that
you're the best option that she has
because in a guy's mind like and a lot
of girls do do this i'm not discounting
that it exists but
they seem to think that it's very hard
to find a girl that's not gonna leave
you for the next best thing number five
men just really want to be appreciated
um a lot of guys
seem to think and i i would agree that
girls have inflated egos because all the
time we're just told you're so beautiful
there's a million like dms we have for
uh like
we have a million dms telling us how
great we are how beautiful we are so a
lot of girls aren't really brought down
to earth
um luckily for me um
i always had a friend group that was
prettier than me so i've been humble
from a very young age um
you know very low
self-esteem um
but when you are in a relationship with
a guy like guys just want to feel like
you appreciate them and you know how
valuable they are because a lot of men
feel really underappreciated in their
relationships because women will do
things like withhold sex if they don't
do like chores or something or
you know um
they're always the ones they file
divorce in 70 to 80 of cases women do so
men really just want a girl that like
appreciates them and knows
that the guy that they have is catch and
it seems like men think that's more and
more rare in present day nowadays
um so yeah that's five things that i've
learned from watching manosphere content
the last
couple of months let me know if you
agree um or if there's any points that
you think i missed don't forget to
subscribe to the channel bring that
notification bell and i will talk to you
guys next time